Elon Musk has finally completed his 44
billion deal to take over Twitter late
Thursday according to regulatory filings
and quickly went to work rebuilding the
company to his vision firing Executives
like CEO parag Agarwal this is what may
change on the platform at the company
and for musk and his other Ventures one
of musk's first orders of business
appeared to be showing several top
Executives the door including Agarwal
and CFO Ned Siegel CNBC first reported
Thursday night musk plans to fire about
75 percent of Twitter employees when he
takes power according to documents and
interviews obtained by The Washington
Post last week indicative of musk's
often hostile relationship with Twitter
and sharp criticism of its content
moderation policies previously accusing
its staff of having a strong left-wing
bias although musk reportedly told
Twitter staff this week that the 75
percent figure is inaccurate musk has
floated several changes to the site
including charging a small fee reducing
the number of fake and spam accounts
from the site changing the content
algorithm to enhance Free Speech
loosening its moderation rules and
adding an edit button for all users in
May musk said he plans to restore the
Twitter account of former president
Donald Trump who the platform banned in
January 2021 due to the risk of further
incitement of violence following the
capital Riot though Trump claims he
wouldn't rejoin and will instead remain
on his new truth social site musk has
also previously stood by Kanye West
calling the rapper his friend before
Twitter bandwest earlier this month for
threatening violence against Jews
wedbush analyst Dan Ives estimated last
week that musk may need to sell another
5 to 10 billion dollars in Tesla stock
to finance the deal adding to the
roughly 30 billion dollars he's already
sold this year and shares of Tesla are
down more than 40 percent since April
4th when musk disclosed his nine percent
stake in Twitter largely due to concerns
about musk's sell-off and the social
media firm pulling his attention away
from the electric vehicle firm the 44
billion dollar price tag for Twitter
will go down as one of the most overpaid
Tech Acquisitions in the history of M A
deals I've said in a note to clients
estimating a 25 billion dollar true
market value for Twitter musk has said
he may use his 44 billion dollar play
thing to build out what he calls his ex
everything app a mobile app which could
bring together a variety of unrelated
services like social media messaging
food delivery and payments under the
same umbrella in the model of tencents
WeChat in China we estimate musk to be
worth 221.5 billion dollars making him
the wealthiest person on the planet by
62 billion dollars musk's Fortune has
tumbled more than 100 billion this year
as Tesla's stock crashes from its
pandemic Peak Twitter stock traded as
low as 32 dollars this summer as doubts
about the deal ever closing peaked
investors betting on the deal going
through make out like Bandits including
billionaire Carl ican who the Wall
Street Journal report stands to profit
as much as 250 million dollars after
buying up more than 500 million dollars
in Twitter shares at about 35 dollars
this summer
[Music]